ein perfekter tag in kärnten begonnen
pionier bataillons zum kommandanten des
bataillons 1 bei den villacher pionieren
wie sie auch genannt werden dann sehen
wir weiter gezogen um eines der größten
projekte die wir vorhaben in villach der
öffentlichkeit auch zu präsentieren
gemeinsam mit dem landeshauptmann mit
landes hat um mit dem bürgermeister von
villach nämlich unsere große kaserne
und jetzt stehen wir hier unser schön am
faaker selber mehr als leistungssport
zentrum er durfte mit den sportlern
plaudern unter es geht jetzt dann noch
weiter wo wir danke sagen dürfen die man
vizeleutnant schmelzer der lebensrettend
eingeschritten sind in einer sehr
schwierigen situation
und dazwischen ein wunderschöner akt
auch noch die der kann man dann von
kärnten wurde ausgezeichnet mit dem
goldenen verdienstkreuz ein perfekter
tag und einfach nur stolz auf was das
bundesheer an vielseitigkeit zu bieten
hat